durch die App skyscanner ist es möglich
jederzeit und von jedem Ort auf der Welt
den günstigsten Flug zu ermitteln ich
habe mich vier Tage auf die Reise
gemacht und jeden Tag aufs Neue den
billigsten Flug gesucht und dann
natürlich gebucht dabei habe ich in
kurzer Zeit unfassbar viel erlebt und
bin am Ende an einem sehr lustigen Ziel
gelandet als kleine Aufgabe habe ich mir
gesetzt an jedem Ort wo ich lande ein
traditionelles Gericht zu essen und ein
lokales Bier zu genießen Props geht raus
an diesen englischen Youtuber vielen
Dank für die Info und damit ein
wunderschönen guten Morgen jo Leute was
geht ab wir haben gerade 6 Uhr und ich
fahre jetzt nach Köln zum Flughafen ich
habe gestern noch den ersten Flug
gebucht und wir fliegen heute haltet
euch fest es wird übelst weit also auch
irgendwo ein bisschen dumm weil dadurch
geht natürlich Zeit verloren aber ich
denke dass ich da dann auch ein bisschen
bleiben werde wir fliegen ins ich glaube
das ist so eine deutsche rentnerinsel
Lanzarote das habe ich nämlich
geschossen für 58 € pro Person das coole
ist nämlich ein Kollege von mir kommt
noch mit der hat sich extra Urlaub
genommen super cool also wir sind jetzt
die nächsten vier fünf sechs Tage
zusammen unterwegs
insgesamt habe ich jetzt hier 116 €
bezahlt es geht auf jeden Fall noch
deutlich günstiger ich denke mal die
nächsten Ziele werden wir dann so
zwischen 12 und 25 € ansteuern mal
schauen wo es dann hingeht aber erster
Stopp wird Lanzarote sein da fliegen
doch immer jede Menge deutsche Rentner
hin oder und das krasse ist wir haben
einfach 22° für mich gar nicht klar noch
kurz Müll wegbringen grüßen so Leute
mittlerweile angekommen in Köln am
Flughafen jetzt geht's los eine Sache
die war mir noch wichtig zu sagen und
zwar würde ich sowas natürlich niemals
machen jetzt nur rein privat weil man
muss ja auch absolut an die Umwelt
denken aber was von mir zu gut halten
muss ich bin ja auch Anfang des Jahres
von London bis Istanbul nur mit dem Zug
gefahren habe da schon einiges für
meinen ökologischen Fußabdruck getan und
jetzt geht's los ich habe Bock wer ist
eigentlich nur auf die Idee gekommen
hier diesen Scheiß Fußboden hin zu
machen das ist der schlimmste Fußboden
an jedem Flughafen wo ich jemals war
ja wegen den Koffern schlimmste Geräusch
hier ist nichts los das letzte Mal wo
ich hier war ging hier die ganze
Schlange
aggressiv das ist die Hauptstadt glaube
ich auch langsam rote B50
deutschen Rentner super so Leute ab
geht's zum Boarding die ganzen Rentner
sind schon drin hallo Danke
zu sehen bist
und ich habe natürlich überhaupt nichts
gegen deutsche Rentner also das soll
nicht irgendwie ist nur Spaß ne bisschen
Spaß verstehen
alle mussten einfach auf die Familien
hinter uns warten weil der Mann noch auf
Toilette war und jeder im ganzen Flieger
weiß dass er noch auf Toilette war und
die Frau ist das so unangenehm
[Musik]
ey geil geil
warte ich muss noch meine Jacke anziehen
naja 24 Grad heute so live Check wie
warm ist es
schon angenehm
ich würde sagen nein wir haben 24 Jahren
wir fahren jetzt erstmal zu unserem
Hotel das habe ich nämlich geschossen
[Musik]
wir sind angekommen hier auf Lanzarote
so nice ich war noch nie ich muss sagen
unsere Unterkunft ist auch super für
diese Nacht das war echt beste Bewertung
auf booking ich habe direkt zugeschlagen
hat nicht mal 80 € bezahlt kann man
absolut nicht meckern Sofa Toilette
Schlafzimmer und ganz ganz wichtig wir
haben hier direkt vor unserer Tür den
Pool und ein paar alemannos die sich
Sonos also so diese Insel Fuerteventura
Gran Canaria Lanzarote sind der komplett
deutsch das merkt man auf jeden Fall
aber ist ja nicht schlimm ne wobei ich
immer cool finde wenn man auch auf
anderweitige Sprachen trifft aber wir
haben ja noch die nächsten Tage und ich
bin mir sicher dass wir noch einiges
passiert wegen jetzt erstmal zum Strand
und dann hoffentlich nice Essen und
später schauen wir mal was hier noch so
geht
früher war hier voll die Eskalation
immer und jetzt haben die Rentner das
übernommen das ist echt also wir sind
gerade auf dem Weg zum Strand und hier
hinter mir ist wirklich eine super
Location für so eine Poolparty aber ich
glaube die ist ja einfach falsch
platziert okay Leute wir sind einfach
schon am Meer gehst du schwimmen oder
sind welche schwimmen es war natürlich
schon naheliegend dass ich an einem Ort
dann noch am Meer landen werde aber das
ist jetzt der erste ist und direkt mit
24 Grad ist schon auf jeden Fall sehr
geil wo geht's als nächstes hin von hier
aus ja ich würde sagen Madrid oder
Barcelona kann sein wir schauen später
mal okay Leute hinter uns ist jetzt hier
der Hafen und unsere Mission bzw mein
Ziel ist ja überall wo wir landen auch
ein traditionelles Gericht und ein
lokales Bier zu trinken hier stelle ich
mir bis jetzt die Frage zählt auch
Schnitzel okay nein wir suchen jetzt
einen lokales Restaurant und dann
erstmal was lokales und dann habe ich
das auch schon abgehakt
[Musik]
bzw Vorspeise das hier sind die Ferien
und bisschen Brot aber die Hauptspeise
kommt auf jeden Fall noch aber diese
hemprocess die gibt's auf jeden Fall
überall in Spanien und ich finde die
sehr nice
[Musik]
ich nehme als Hauptspeise auf jeden Fall
Fisch mag ich so gerne und das Bier
fehlt noch
so Leute Abendessen ist fertig war auf
jeden Fall super lecker das Bier habe
ich noch nicht erwischt das gibt's erst
später in der Bar aber wir gehen jetzt
gleich noch Fußball gucken dortmund
spielt vorher müssen wir aber auch noch
die nächste connection buchen das machen
wir jetzt erstmal als erstes also wir
gehen jetzt erstmal wieder ins Hotel und
dann geht's hier ins lazarote Nachtleben
falls es das gibt okay Leute jetzt
wird's spannend ich zeige euch mal wie
das jetzt abläuft wir buchen jetzt für
morgen von Lanzarote aus den günstigsten
Flug zum nächsten Ziel und jetzt gibt
man einfach hier ein alle Orte erkunden
ich bin ja hier auf skyscanner und wir
brauchen nur den Hinflug für morgen 8
März Zack und dann gehen wir hier auf
Suche okay es geht wieder nach Spanien
habe ich mir eigentlich schon fast
gedacht das einzige was noch hätte Sinn
machen können wer vielleicht Italien
oder so
der kompostera also ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich habe davon noch nie gehört nee
oder zack Angebot prüfen über Travis
Start kein Plan was das ist und dann
geht's morgen weiter nach Santiago okay
Leute ich Buch das jetzt dann geht's
weiter
zu local
you so ein Bier bitte das ist Malaga
Bier ich hoffe es schmeckt groß
Challenge erfüllt beim ersten Stopp
gut auf geht's Dortmund kämpfen und
siegen
[Musik]
so erster Tag ist vorbei wir waren jetzt
noch in der Stadt noch in der Bar und so
ein bisschen Fußball geguckt jetzt
geht's schlafen morgen geht's weiter wir
haben mittlerweile auch schon halb zwei
aber der Tag war erfolgreich und hat
echt viel Spaß gemacht ich bin gespannt
was morgen so ansteht
so Leute was geht guten Morgen wir sind
aufgestanden haben jetzt hier 11 Uhr
mittlerweile und machen uns das auf dem
Weg was nice zu frühstücken auf jeden
Fall ist das Wetter heute wieder
bombastisch Sonnenschein ja wir genießen
jetzt hier noch die nächsten fünf
Stunden weil dann geht's schon zum
Flughafen und wir fliegen ja nach
Santiago und da ist das Wetter nicht so
gut 20 Jahre klingt eigentlich wie
Amerika ne aber das ist ja ein Spanier
da haben wir 12 Grad und Regen aber ist
auch nicht so schlimm also hier ist es
echt super willst du noch was sagen
wir hatten heute Nacht kein Wasser und
sind einfach fast verdurstet hast jetzt
das erste Wasser seit 14 Stunden erstmal
ein Cappuccino cool live und ein Wasser
ja bitte ein großes geil
[Musik]
oder
verarbeitet
Videos mit diesem Rucksack hier
unterwegs und man muss eigentlich sagen
dieser Rucksack ist so unpraktisch weil
der passt fast nichts rein aber ich bin
irgendwie zu kaufen deswegen kommentiert
mal alle Alex schicken
hier geht's jetzt noch weiter hoch und
dann sind wir schon beim Frühstücks
Restaurant das hat auf jeden Fall auch
eine stabile Aussicht genauso wie jetzt
schon und ich habe die ganze Zeit hier
meine Jacke hängen weil die brauche ich
ja später wieder wow geil da vorne paar
Jetskis neue sollen wir Jetskis klauen
guck mal
[Musik]
also man muss zwar sagen auf Lanzarote
geht so nicht viel weil die echt nur
viele ältere Leute sind aber die Insel
ist wirklich wunderschön und ich bin
super happy hier mal gewesen zu sein
auch wenn man sich das hier wieder
anschaut geil nur noch der Bereich wo
wir gewohnt haben das alles das ist fast
nur Touristen also da ist ein Apartment
neben dem anderen ich hätte mir auch
gerne mal mehr vom Landesinneren
angeschaut auch mal natürlich ein Auto
für und ich glaube da hinten ist sogar
vor dem Touren dann weiß man das sehen
kann na ja so jetzt zum breakfast so
schön hier guck mal was sagen muss wir
sind jetzt hier im Frühstücks Restaurant
es ist alles so günstig hier das ist
echt krass hätte ich nicht gedacht dafür
so ein großes Frühstück und 6 € boah das
ist hier schmecken danke
[Musik]
guten Appetit traditionell spanisches
Frühstück aus Irland
[Musik]
Wasser kurz vorher zum Flughafen müssen
geil das ist doch ein guter Abschluss
[Musik]
so Leute weiter geht's wir sind jetzt am
Flughafen und fliegen jetzt weiter nach
Santiago de compostelia oder so ja es
war eine angenehme Taxifahrt wir haben
uns gerade noch zum Abschluss zwei
Bierchen gegönnt das merkt man auch
gerade aber jetzt erstmal lange Sachen
anziehen weil das Problem ist wir haben
dort 12 Grad let's go zum Check-In
Santiago ganz unten das hört sich so
richtig geil an oder es hört sich
ehrlich richtig Spanisch an kann man
sagen mal gucken ob Santiago auch gut
wird so Leute ich habe mittlerweile
lange Sachen an und wir fliegen jetzt
weiter ich habe Niesen Sonnenbrand
bekommen ich kann mich nicht dran
erinnern weil ich das letzte mal so
einen schlimmen Sonnenbad hatte aber
egal jetzt geht's ganz kalte hier ist
auf jeden Fall nix los
[Musik]
Alter Leute könnt euch bei der Geburt
also
und während wir jetzt hier mittlerweile
sogar in der Luft sind kommen wir auch
zum Sponsor des heutigen Videos das ist
auch eine Premiere ich glaube ich habe
noch nie ein Sponsor im Flugzeug
vorgestellt und zwar nein das gibt's
nicht okay wir haben das Problem gelöst
der sponsert ist heutigen Videos ist
CyberGhost VPN CyberGhost hilft euch im
Internet egal ob ihr privat oder
geschäftlich unterwegs seid sicherer zu
surfen dabei wird eure IP-Adresse
verschlüsselt und eure ganzen Daten sind
safe unterwegs außerdem habt ihr
natürlich die Möglichkeit über 40
Streaming Anbieter egal ob Netflix Prime
Video was auch immer überall unbegrenzt
und vor allem uneingeschränkt weltweit
zu nutzen und dadurch dass CyberGhost
9000 Server in 91 Ländern besitzt ist
eine zuverlässige VPN Verbindung
eigentlich immer gegeben natürlich kann
ich selber Basti auf dem iPhone
verwenden geht noch am MacBook Windows
PC Android Gerät wie auch immer ich bin
jetzt natürlich gerade im Flugzeug habe
das aber eben schon mal für euch
aufgezeichnet so sieht das aus wirklich
super nutzerfreundlich ihr könnt euch
einfach in irgendein Land einwählen und
Amerika let's go was auch super cool ist
ihr müsst nur einen Account erstellen
und können sieben Geräte gleichzeitig
nutzen also besser geht's eigentlich gar
nicht mit meinem Link den jetzt hier
eingeblendet seht bekommt ihr bis zu 83%
Rabatt also ungefähr nur 2 € pro Monat
also echt nicht viel und falls es euch
doch nicht gefällt was ich glaube gibt's
noch 45 Tage Geld zurück Garantie also
Checks aus und wir chillen jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen weil dann geht's gleich
weiter der Tag wird noch anstrengend
angekommen in Santiago de compostelia
direkt komplettes Gegenteil hier ist
nichts los ich habe vorsichtshalber
schon mal meine Jacke angezogen wir
holen uns jetzt ein Taxi und fahren dann
zum Hotel das haben wir auch wieder
geschossen 62 € sieht super aus und ich
freue mich auf den Aufenthalt hier und
mal gucken was heute noch so geht wir
hatten übrigens voll die Turbulenzen der
hatte bisschen Angst war echt gefährlich
das war echt gefährlich aus ja wir haben
es ja geschafft wir haben es geschafft
jetzt warten noch kurz auf unseren
Koffer
und dann gehen wir weiter hier ist
wirklich gar nichts los
so angekommen hier eine Altstadt hier
muss irgendwo das Hotel sein
nein wir sind auf jeden Fall angekommen
es hat geklappt geklappt mittlerweile
angekommen im Hotel das Zimmer ist
wirklich übelst nice für 62 Euro kann
man hier echt nicht meckern ist
natürlich nicht so groß dafür ist der
Fernseher umso größer und ja sehr bequem
Alter guck mal gegenüber der hat voll
die krasse Wohnung der Typ einziger
Nachteil neben meinem fetten Sonnenbrand
wir haben schon ziemlich spät ist es
schon 11:45 Uhr wir sind halt erst so
spät geflogen aber wir gehen jetzt noch
los weil das soll ja auch eine
Studentenstadt sein und hier soll
einiges gehen wir schauen mal ansonsten
habe ich mir jetzt überlegt dass ich so
mache dass wir erst morgen den nächsten
Flug buchen und auch schauen ob wir dann
morgen schon weiter fliegen oder erst
übermorgen je nachdem wie es uns hier
gefällt einfach ganz spontan bist du
schon motiviert eigentlich oder nicht so
ja okay jetzt gerade nicht so sieht das
übrigens vor unserem Hotel aus und hier
in diesem kleinen Laden da was auch
immer da abgeht da ist auf jeden Fall
irgendwie eine Party
also hier ist zwar nichts los aber da
ist eine Bar da gehen wir jetzt erstmal
rein und dann schauen wir mal ob das die
einzige war hier ist irgendwie ein
bisschen
das ist echt crazy hier
[Musik]
so Challenge eins local Bier wir haben
hier noch nie von gehört aber haben wir
direkt schon im Kasten 2 € probiert auf
jeden Fall okay
sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine
Geisterstadt
[Musik]
noch um 3 Uhr da Hotdog Essen das ist
der letzte Laden der hier auf hat kann
man auf jeden Fall hingehen und jetzt
geht's ins Bettchen Leute was geht und
damit guten Morgen aus Santiago de
compostia das hier ist unser Balkon der
aber allerdings also geht nicht auf
jetzt sieht man das hier wir waren ja
gestern noch hier unterwegs jetzt sieht
man das auch zum ersten Mal in hellen
war auf jeden Fall lustig gestern man
muss nur sagen hier ist alles irgendwie
schon so ein bisschen ausgestorben die
Straßen es gibt Sachen wo man dann
abends hingehen kann viele Studenten
wurden ja aber es schaut doch so aus als
wären echt super viele Wohnungen frei
mal schauen wie das jetzt am Tag
aussieht wir werden jetzt noch schön
hier frühstücken gehen schön
traditionell hier gibt's ziemlich vieles
weil ich brauche noch meinen
traditionelles Essen und dann schauen
wir mal was der Tag zu bringt wie man
jetzt auf meinem hellen sehen kann hier
sind halt überall so kleine Katzen und
es ist alles ja auf jeden Fall Altbau
aber schön und ich glaube die meisten
Leute die hier wohnen haben noch eine
Kamera gesehen
[Musik]
eigentlich hätte ich aber sogar gedacht
dass es hier auch ziemlich touristisch
ist weil was vielleicht eine
interessante Information ist Santiago de
compostille hallo ist die letzte Stadt
bzw das Ende vom Jakobsweg okay genug
mit Geschichte für heute so hier vorne
ist jetzt unser Café gestern sind wir
auch schon lange gegangen der war hier
allerdings nichts los was ist das doch
oder nicht
ich kann nicht so gut Spanisch und ich
verstehe nicht alles aber naja einfach
mal blind bestellen wird schon
also hier gibt's auf jeden Fall so
Kuchen einfach dann haben wir gar nicht
bestellt aber sieht lecker aus
[Musik]
rosa brutal Kaffee auch super und jetzt
habe ich so noch nie gesehen
[Musik]
wow also ich muss sagen das war wirklich
das Beste Brötchen oder das beste Brot
was ich je gegessen habe und es war
unfassbar günstig 15 € für das alles
zusammen hätte zwei frisch gepresste
o-säfte echt geil also hier ist die Welt
noch in Ordnung Preis Leistung 10 von 10
und ja echt leckeres Frühstück okay
Leute wir sind jetzt noch mal im Hotel
um den nächsten Flug zu buchen wir
könnten theoretisch auch noch einen Tag
hier bleiben allerdings haben wir uns
dazu entschieden das nicht zu tun weil
hier einfach nicht so viel geht also
irgendwie ist es hier so ein bisschen
ausgestorben und von der Umgebung hier
auch nicht so schön deswegen würden wir
gern weiter vielleicht geht's ja diesmal
in ein anderes Land das finde ich
eigentlich ziemlich geil weil dann
hätten wir noch ein anderes Land gesehen
vielleicht nicht Deutschland wäre also
so wie es aussieht ich weiß auch nicht
oben steht einfach immer doof aber das
ist halt okay
Spanien okay Malle dicker 13 Euro aber
scheiß drauf Mann
18 € pro Person wieder mit wühlen da
sind wir gestern noch geflogen
[Musik]
okay Leute ich Buch jetzt mal alle und
dann geht's in fünf Stunden noch mal
wir sind hier auf jeden Fall jetzt noch
ein bisschen rumgesteppt man muss halt
sagen so ganz überzeugen tut mich diese
Stadt nicht hier geht nicht viel es
sieht echt alles gleich aus super viele
alte Gebäude was irgendwo schönes aber
wenn es so unbelebt aussieht an vielen
Ecken auch wiederum nicht Wege sind sehr
steil und wir wissen auch nicht so ganz
was wir jetzt noch machen sollen leider
wir sind wieder am Flughafen und jetzt
geht's weiter noch mal eigentlich noch
so gut oder so ne Stimme wir brauchen
jetzt noch so und so ein T-Shirt
brauchen wir noch mit Laufen geil oder
so ab ins Boarding und auf nach Malle
die heißt die Mutter von Nick oder Mama
und keine Ahnung echt komisch also in
Deutschland ist das anders
[Musik]
richtig geil ist ein Kollege von mir der
hier auf Malle wohnt der holt uns jetzt
erstmal ab und dann gehen wir was essen
auf jeden Fall noch gut rein danke fürs
abholen und wir gehen jetzt erstmal wo
gehen wir jetzt hin
und dann genießt den letzten Tag von
unserer Kurzreise und ich freue mich
auch
ich bin einfach zum ersten Mal hier das
ist diese weltberühmte Schinkenstraße
glaube ich und da vorne ist der
Bierkönig
[Musik]
na gut geschlafen wie ein Baby Leute was
geht ab ich wünsche euch einen
wunderschönen guten Morgen Ich habe
gestern jetzt nicht mehr so viel mit
gefilmt weil einfach eins zum anderen
kamen wir sind da noch in diesem
Bierkönig gegangen da war ich auch
vorher noch nie ich war noch nie so am
Ballermann und ja dann habe ich halt
einfach nicht mehr gefilmt aber das kann
ja auch mal passieren das gut ist der
Kai der wohnt hier gerade und wir
konnten jetzt auch schlafen also echt
wunderschön genau im Landesinneren hier
sind super viele Palmen und ja wir
hatten gestern auf jeden Fall richtig
viel Spaß sie noch am letzten Abend auf
Malle ich weiß es fehlt noch das Local
Bier und es fehlt dann noch das lokale
essen muss mal gucken ob es auf Malle
überhaupt irgendwas lokales hier gibt
noch weil heute Abend geht's zurück nach
Deutschland und dann sind diese drei
turbulenten Tag auch schon rum wieso
Hunde sind so cool hey ich hab's nicht
rein
in Deutschland sind irgendwie so zwei
Grad wird so gerne einfach noch hier
bleiben weil das Wetter einfach zu
angenehm ist wie fand das gestern im
Bierkönig es war angenehm muss ich sagen
waren zwar nicht so viele Leute da aber
es hat Spaß gemacht ich zeige euch mal
wo wir heute Nacht schlafen haben einmal
hier und einmal hier ich glaube das war
sogar das bequemste hier neben alles
einfach so ein Feld und da sind Esel ach
jetzt die sind ja ganz schön weit weg ja
[Musik]
ich bin einfach so fertig ey die letzten
Tage haben es mir gegeben so Leute wär
mir kurz noch gegessen bei 800 km/h
Windgeschwindigkeit am Ballermann und
jetzt geht's zum Flughafen und dann war
es das aber scheiß drauf Malle ist nur
einmal im Jahr
ole ole und schalala
ich bin zum ersten Mal hier hast du
gestern Nacht waren wir auch hier aber
an der Promenade war ich noch nie vielen
Dank für alles
wir sehen uns ja
das war doch ein gutes Finale oder ja
auf jeden Fall also hat sich gelohnt so
leute wir fliegen jetzt auf jeden Fall
zurück das war echt eine coole Reise wir
haben in drei Tagen unfassbar viel
erlebt und ich hoffe das Video hat Euch
gefallen ich werde das jetzt hier schon
beenden ich habe auf jeden Fall vor
sowas zu machen vielleicht dann sogar so
eine europa-edition dass ich halt
wirklich von Land zu Land fliegen muss
könnt ihr gerne mal einen Daumen nach
oben da lassen abonniert den Kanal und
wir sehen uns haut rein ciao